[Music]
here in this video we will dive into the
movie Independence Day and its sequel
Resurgence and discuss everything about
the queen Harvester alien we will first
take a look at their history on Earth
then their species profile and then
ending with the Queen's design biology
her bios suit and how she commands the
interstellar aliens SW it's pretty
interesting to have a technos swarm
alien species that embes horror sci-fi
and fantasy aspects into one so let's
take a deeper look into
it the first recorded interaction
between humanity and these Harvester
aliens was in 1947 when a spaceship of
their scratch landed on the Foster Ranch
outside of Roswell New Mexico in the
crash two aliens were killed while a
third was seriously injured so on July
2nd 1996 the the Harvesters dispatched a
mother ship to Earth and began their
invasion in what became known as the war
of 1996 arriving in massive CI sized
destroyers the Harvesters used varying
tactics including human satellites to
relay signals between their vessels and
coordinate their attacks destroying
nearly every major city in the world
during their initial strike they were
later however defeated by the use of a
computer virus to disable the shields of
their ships and also by a daring
surgical strike into the mother ship
with a nuclear bomb which set off a
chain reaction that crippled the rest of
the ships on Earth so although defeated
in 1996 many Harvesters survived some
managed to establish a level of
resistance Against Humanity on Earth but
were ultimately either eliminated or
captured by human forces however prior
to their defeat the hster sent a
distressed signal to Deep Space Warning
the rest of their species of their
failure and a distress call was received
by one of the Queens which made its way
to the planet inside an even larger
Mothership with a swarm of her minions
by her side this culminated in the
second war of 2016 20 years after the
first Invasion and even though Humanity
had prepared for such an encounter what
they got was still way more than they
could
handle so in the vast expanse of the
Galaxy there exist these aliens
possessing Advanced intellect and
Technology they scour the stars in
search of planets to exploit with
ruthless efficiency they decimate
indigenous life forms and drain their
planets of their resources to feel their
insatiable hunger for growth and
propagation however the real origins of
these Harvester aliens are shrouded in
mystery with their true name lost to
time and their legacy are just the
countless civilizations they have
obliterated in their wake the hster
aliens look a lot like the Martians from
the war of the world's remake movie at
least to the Layman physically the
Harvesters resemble slender bluish gray
quasi humanoids standing 3 to 4T tall
they have two long arms and two feet
with two digits each their heads feature
en large rear sections kind of like the
crest with large pupiless reflective
eyes that are silvery and they also seem
to have white nictating membranes
instead of normal eyelids they lack any
visible mouth and communication is
achieved through a sophisticated form of
telepathy or ESP extra sensory
perception they can also exert mind
control by attaching the BIOS suit's
tentacles to the victim's necks and
using their vocal cause to communicate
with humans these normal Harvesters are
frail and can be killed easily so that
is why they encase themselves inside
their bios suits which gives them a more
menacing appearance and with it they
stand 99 ft tall or 2.7 M they have two
arms and legs and a multitude of
tentacles is Sprout out from their
bags now finally let's take a look at
the queen Harvester so these aliens
usually Traverse through space and
colossal mother ships each approximately
5,000 km in diameter these ships are
overseen by a single Harvester Queen
inside of it the dominant individual of
their species who command the Swarm and
also the release of numerous smaller
Scout motherships to scout the stars for
potential planets to invade each around
400 km in diameter to find new planets
for consumption each of these Scout
mother ships carry 83 City destroyers
massive vessels with a diameter of 25 km
each so with this enormous force behind
her the Harvester Queen serves as their
leader and also the matriarch of their
species embodying the collective
consciousness of their entire Hive swarm
their hive mine the Harvester Queen is
massive compared to the normal drones
dwarfing them and their war machines in
every aspect while the workers are seen
to be 3 to 4T tall and around 9 ft or
2.7 M tall in their bios suits and the
soldiers around 12T tall the Queen by
itself is a massive monstrosity that
stands around 131 ft or 40 m tall
without the suit and with it she stands
an imposing 60 M or 200 ft in height the
size of a Kaiju she is beige grayish in
coloration with a few parts of her skin
that is translucent and shows some sort
of a bioluminous blood causing through
her entire body she resembles a queen
xenom Mo in certain ways with a large
Crest on her head and two smaller hands
on the chest alongside four longer Limbs
and being B mechanical in nature and
these four longer limbs as well as the
others all end in two fingers two digits
unlike the drones the queen seems to
have organic tentacles that emerge from
her bag so even though she looks frail
without her bodysuit her size infers
that she can still smash anything she
wants to she is the only member of a
species that possesses a working mouth
which has teeth similar to those of
humans and she also seems to possess a
massive insect like abdomen her bio suit
like the others of the workers and the
soldiers are more monstrous
representations of their initial
appearance the Queen's bios suit in
particular is way larger than the queen
itself increasing her height to 60 M or
200 ft so while the queen has six limbs
in total the BIOS suit gives her an
extra two to control so in total the
queen Harvester has 14 appendages okay
let's take a look at these four organic
looking legs and an additional two
heavily armored w as well as two long
arms that emerge from the chest to
handle weapons and stuff these along
with the six tentacles that Sprout out
from the back gives the queen harer a
high level of mobility and handling
capabilities the bit is protected by a
powerful Shield generator that can
generate a force field to block out any
form of attack be it projectiles or
energy beams and even in theory it can
withstand a coal fusion
bomb so the queen seems to be the only
individual of the the Harvester alien
species to have a truly sentient mind
with which it uses to control the hive
like some sort of a swarm command unit
completely merciless these Queens show
no interest in peaceful coexistence
opting instead for total Annihilation
and genocide of the planet's life forms
although seemingly evil this doesn't
really seem to equate to a true
malevolence as they are only truly
motivated by their survival instincts
like social insects seen on Earth and
although not truly insects in any way
they exhibit some sort of a youth social
behavior similar to many social Earth
arthropods with a hierle car system that
has the Queen on top and the workers or
soldiers beneath it with all of them
working in unison for the propagation of
the species but then again the queen
hunting and searching for the sphere on
Earth does point to some sort of an evil
intent towards the object like a form of
hatred or enmity or even jealousy or
Vengeance anyway that's all we have
about the queen Harvester for now so if
you like this video then watch this
other one as well and do check out our
channel for other monster content you
know movie monster content we might have
things you haven't seen before or things
that YouTube hasn't recommended in quite
a while anyway like subscribe and we'll
see you in the next video take care
fam